Speaker 1: Let's go next to Ricardo. Or is it
Ricardo from Italy? You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Oh, awesome. So very quick, very quick
context from my end. So I'm Italian by birth,
but I only live there as a as a young kid. And
then I worked for 20 years in Costa Rica, and now
I'm in the Boston area and I've been working here
for five years. Got it. So. So my question is
like the modern world is really not suited for for
the current way of doing politics in the way that
I truly have never felt really represented by any
political party. And I don't really have a voice
because I can only vote in a place where I never
lived as an adult and I've never paid taxes. So
if I vote in Italy, I get called a bunch of names
saying, You really have a saying here because you
don't really have to face the consequences. You've
been gone for so long. Yeah, yeah, exactly. In
the U.S., I can't really complain because I'm
not a citizen yet. I pay the same, if not more
taxes for being a foreigner working here. Same
thing in Costa Rica for the previous 20 years,
right? I was always the outsider and never really
had any representation. And if you think about it,
the whole concept of U.S. democracy is based on no
taxation, no representation, right? So it's it's
crazy that we live in a world where I don't really
have a true saying on anything yet. I have to
bear the consequences of other people's choices.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, to play devil's advocate,
there are some who would say, you
know, you do have a say in that
as a resident, you can still lobby your elected
officials and they still are supposed to listen
to you even though you're not a citizen, but you
certainly don't have a vote in the way everybody
else does. Yeah, I don't really have an answer.
I mean, you're you're not you're not wrong.
And I think what some might say is if you've been
in other places that long, you really should go
through the process of getting citizenship so you
can get that vote. But no, you're you're you're in
a kind of in-between situation. I understand
Speaker 2: it. It takes so long and doing
things the right way. Yes, it's really
more difficult than most people that are
born in this country would ever understand.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Absolutely. Yeah.
Speaker 2: What part of Italy are you from?
I was born in Milan.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK. I've been a beautiful city.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, the good
thing is that I can speak Italian,
Spanish and English, so at least I have that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you know, interestingly,
when I was in Torino for a wedding a couple
of years ago, there were a lot of immigrants
there from Central America, and they spoke
English, Spanish and Italian. All very well.
Awesome. Yeah. All right. Thank you. Thanks so
much for the call. I appreciate it. All right,
very good. OK, everybody, that will do it for
today, I know more people wanted to talk to me.
I know it, I see it, I feel it, but I can't get
to everybody, so we will take live calls again.